Rob's World!
What's up guys?! I hope you're having a
great holiday season. Since my last video
poll, I've been practicing how to make
the magic ball and also the mini magic
balls so I can come up with a tutorial.
After I made the mini magic ball I
wanted to make it a little bit larger, so
I tried it with larger paper... but then I
wanted to go a little bit larger than
this one, so I taped two pieces of paper
together to get this one. Then I said,
"You know what? I might as well give
myself a challenge!," so I taped together
24 pieces of paper to make this Super
Jumbo Giant Mega Magic Mini Ball, I
filmed myself doing it and then I posted
in the Community section on my channel
to see if people wanted to see, it and
just about all the comments said that
they wanted to see how I made it. So I'm
going to show you a time-lapse video of
me making it. Then, after seeing the
process of how long it takes, if you
still want to see me make a tutorial for
it, leave a comment below and give this
video a thumbs up! Also, I'm not gonna say
how long it took me, but if you guess and
post your answer down in the comments
below and you come close, I'll post that
answer in the next video! Thanks for
watching, I hope you guys enjoy it!
Owww!
Well, it's all done
I just gotta break it in now. Check it
out. The Mega Jumbo Giant Mini Magic Ball...if you can say that.
Just like with the regular sized mini magic ball,  you can press it down into a flat shape
and then turn it inside out like a
flower and you can flip it over and you
see it's a little bit like the Kaleidoscope.
Then you can just squish it.
Flip it over and do the same exact thing!
Leela, what do you think of the Magic Ball?
You like it? What about this one, you like
this one better? There you go, it's a new
scratching ball. Thanks for watching guys
and be sure to click on the button right
on Leela's face in order to SUBSCRIBE! Alright, say bye Leela.
Jumbo Giant Mega Mini B---
Mega magic mini ball. Mega mini. Mega magic...Mega Mini Magic Ball!